there is a rape culture on American
college campuses data don't lie four out
of 1000 college women every year or
raped or sexually assaulted eight point
five percent of college women experience
forcible rape while in college
definitions of sexual assault and forced
sex are being hopelessly muddied by
sexual assault education on campuses
relations between women and men are
adversarial there is a battle of the
sexes award between the sexes there is
at this moment a sort of culture for
young women in many cases of encouraging
them to see rape in incidents that you
know maybe should be seen as poor
decision-making that we're having a
debate like this at all is evidence that
I think we live in a rape culture
imagine if 20% of all Jewish students on
college campuses had swastikas painted
on their on their drunken bodies during
drunken parties how would people feel if
for instance somebody decided to put
signs on mirrors in a Muslim Center on
campus saying you are looking at
somebody who can stop terrorism welcome
to this seventh debate seventh debate of
the second season of the solo forum both
to those in our physical audience at the
subculture Theatre in downtown Manhattan
and to the thousands around the globe
who are watching us on live streaming
the we are a monthly debate series that
features topics of special interest to
libertarians and aims to enhance social
and professional ties within New York
City's libertarian community this is an
Oxford style debate in which the
audience initially votes for against or
undecided on the resolution and then
again after the debate is over whoever
moves the vote in his or her favor is
declared the winner go into Soho
vote.com to cast your initial vote
you'll find that tonight's resolution
reads there is a rape culture on college
campuses that creates an unsafe
environment for female students Kate to
chair Bo would you please come to the
stage
and give people a briefing about the
voting okay so in order to vote you go
to Soho forum I mean Soho vote calm and
if you haven't been able to login yet
you'll notice that around the room we
have some posters and that'll explain to
you how to get on to the Wi-Fi so again
that's Soho Volcom and you just you know
you indicate your vote once the vote
begins I mean once the debate begins
we're gonna close voting and we'll let
you know at that point and then you'll
be asked to vote again at the end of the
debate why you are considering your vote
bear in mind that we are partnered with
Reason magazine and in presenting these
debates and you can catch audio of all
our events on the reason podcast which
you'll find in the iTunes Store you'll
also be able to catch a video thanks
also to the Smith Family Foundation for
making this series possible for more
information and to buy tickets to our
future debates go to our website at V
Soul formed org I'm Jean Epstein
director of the Sola forum with every
soul forum we have a warm-up act and
this evening we are pleased to bring
back the great comic Dave Smith
Dave's podcast part of the problem has
an enormous following which certainly
includes me and not just because I've
been honored to be a guest on Dave's
show the show's title part of the
problem is derived from that famous line
I assume if you're not part of the
solution you're part of the problem Dave
please come on stage and tell us how to
be part of the solution
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much everybody
how are we how about around for Jean huh
go ahead Jean Epstein puts together this
wonderful series you know when Jean
first asked me if I wanted to tell some
jokes before a debate about rape I
thought to myself yeah it's every comics
dream of course why would I not jump at
that opportunity and I understand that
there's libertarians here we have one of
our debaters as leans to the left
I would imagine but you know we might
disagree on the subject but when it
comes to the topic of sexual assault I
can always count on the left to have a
good sense of humor so I appreciate that
jokes are always allowed it's very
listen it's very sure is there a problem
with sexual assault in the country I'm
sure there is but I know like all of you
we can count on Donald Trump to get to
the bottom of it so I'm sure whatever
this problem is will soon be resolved
all right sorry I don't wanna I'm not
part of the problem on this issue okay
Jean I'm engaged now my fiancee is here
so yeah thank you women in the audience
for applauding I appreciate that yeah I
got out of the game in perfect time as
soon as the me two moments started I was
like I'm settling down this is not AI
can't navigate these waters I can't it's
too much I feel bad for some of these
young guys I don't even know how you go
about dating these day you know you go
up to a woman you're like can I buy you
a drink and she's like actually I'm
gonna call the cops yeah all right well
I guess that I'll count that as a lesson
learned in this I for the record I was a
supporter of the me to movement until
they started ruining comedians and then
I was like too far okay too far
stick to Hollywood and I'll be with you
you take out all those leftists in
Hollywood I'll cheer this thing on then
you're like Louie CK I'm like all right
let's let's reel it in a little bit I
don't Louie CK he got ruined because he
was he was masturbating in front of
women I think he's the only guy to ever
get ruined for sexually assaulting
himself is
as I but I'm no historian so I can't
tell you the and then Aziz Ansari he
went down and I don't know if you read
the story on babe
dot-com which we all go to every morning
but the story with Aziz was he went out
with a woman they got some drinks they
went back to his place
they got naked they both performed oral
sex on each other and then he tried to
have intercourse with her now in my day
we called that a date but evidently it's
a whole different time that we're living
in now I don't know the weird thing is
that I always thought Louie CK was like
an amazing brilliant comedian and then
when that stuff came out it's like ah
Louie I I always thought as he's kind of
stunk and then when that stuff came out
I was like go Aziz you know like waste
sent the three people just just left on
my favorite and the crowd by the way
this is I slice up the craft
it's a tough time I don't know what to
say I don't this is why I settled down
I'm very happy with my fiance I'm never
gonna be a part of a hashtag that's what
I know deep in my heart I always hate by
the way that's what I recommend to young
guys who are out there just settle down
you don't have to have these problems
just don't go out and even risk anything
just find a great woman and be good to
her you know sorry I was just trying to
win points after those question of all
rape jokes I always say I hate when men
like [ __ ] about their wife or their
girlfriend I hate that they're that you
know as men like Oh mother
ball-and-chain and it's like it's a
voluntary relationship you know if you
hate it that much leave it's like if you
were in a prison and then they were like
we're gonna get rid of the cells and
also there's no more guards and the door
the front door is wide open and then you
were just sitting there and you're like
man jail sucks
like well I have a solution take a walk
like what what are we doing here I do I
love these events Jane I always do
especially now that Reason magazine is a
part of this it's unbelievable yeah we
get all 7d libertarians in New York in
one room together it's an amazing it's
an amazing moment
the world is fun these days no matter
what you think I don't know libertarians
are split some of you guys love Trump
some of you guys hate Trump but you all
have to admit it is entertaining as [ __ ]
like there is no it is fun I turn on the
news every day just to make sure Trump
still president I don't even know you
just got to turn it on for like five
minutes you're like all right we're
still doing this let's keep moving with
that that's right
don't you always think like they a lot
of people think he's gonna get impeached
I don't know you know I don't know maybe
he'll get impeached I couldn't tell you
for sure but I don't think anyone's
gonna beat Trump in an election I don't
think they can
you got a debate that guy and no one can
out debate Trump Trump found a whole new
way to debate you know you remember when
Hillary Clinton was trying to debate
Trump oh man she just couldn't handle it
she was up there being a traditional
politician and she would say traditional
politician E things like Hillary Clinton
would be like you know the rhetoric
Donald Trump uses is just reckless and
then Trump would be like your husband's
are rapists like Hillary's like Jesus
what he wrote I like Hillary second
Hillary we have 30 seconds to respond if
you'd like to just like wow my husband's
a rapist I didn't have anything prepared
for that I I've asked him to stop I
don't know I just like he's not gonna
he's not that kind of stuff and I'll
wrap up on that but that was the one you
know for everything Donald Trump may
have said on a tape I grew up I'm a 90s
kid Bill Clinton was our president you
know and that guy's got a track record
just shy of Bill Cosby like he's a how
come he never gets in trouble for it
yeah on a scale of one to Cosby Bill
Clinton is like an 8 which is pretty bad
don't get me I'm a zero okay I don't
have none of that
Bill Clinton you've seen him these days
looks weird looks weird Bill Clinton did
it all wrong he was like fat in the
middle of his life and then got skinny
and old age like that's not how it's
supposed to go all right you're supposed
to be in shape and then when you get
older you can let yourself go a little
bit now I just got to watch Bill Clinton
plus the skin of old Bill Clinton walk
around and it's it's uncomfortable well
as far as opening for a debate on rape
this is about as good as I think I can
do so I do appreciate all you guys
coming out enjoy the conversation thank
you very much thank you mr. Epstein
[Applause]
thank you Dave Smith and do listen to a
show part of the problem you can see you
could hear some of the intellects some
of the insights underneath those jokes
Dave shares some pretty piercing
insights on his show part of the problem
well arguing for the affirmative on the
resolution
we have sociologist Michael Kimmel
professor Kimmel please come to the
stage
[Applause]
opposing the resolution we have
journalist Cathy young Cathy please come
to the stage Michael Kimmel you have ten
minutes to defend the resolution there
is a rape culture on college campuses
that creates an unsafe environment for
female students Kate please close the
voting take it away Michael thank you
two words rape culture okay let me take
them one at a time pretty much every
single study that involves statistically
adequate sampling comes up with the same
percentages here are just a few National
Institute of justice between one-fifth
and one-fourth attempted or completed
while in college ninety percent know
their assailants more than half were by
a person that the woman was dating less
than five percent reported to the police
three other large-scale surveys taken
together come up with a rate of 8.5% of
college women experienced forcible rape
while in college when you add
incapacitated or attempted rape the rate
jumps to between 14 and 26 percent these
do not include cases of unwanted
touching grabbing fondling or what we
might call trumping or even
psychological coercion individual campus
studies find similar rates University
New Hampshire one-third Ole Miss 27%
Michigan 22 point five percent in the
last 12 months perhaps the most
methodological rigorous study ever done
on a college campus is being done right
now at Columbia based on surveys
participant observations and interviews
since entry 22 percent of students
reported at least one incident of sexual
assault twenty-eight percent women 38
percent LGBT and 12.5 percent men more
than 10 percent of men may be now some
of the men in the room will believe me
when I say there's a rape culture on
college campuses on aggregate the best
estimates are that between 7 and 10
percent of women experience
forcible rape while in college and
somewhere between fourteen and twenty
six percent experienced sexual assault
does this add up to rape culture will
you tell me if not ask yourself what
percentage might work for you and it's
true there's been no nationally
representative survey of all college
students we don't have the best data
that we could have why because we live
in a rape culture a culture that
actually doesn't want to know doesn't
want to believe women now what's been
the campus response to this in 2014 the
Senate surveyed 440 colleges and
universities and they found less than 5%
of rape victims report their attacks to
law enforcement half of those
institutions only half provide a hotline
for victims two-fifths have not
conducted a single investigation in the
past five years one-fifth give their
athletics department oversight on sexual
violence so of course what's been the
response of the administration to
improve or to improve right no they
decided simply to change the metrics
frankly that's how you know you live in
a rape culture to conclude this part I
know no serious credentialed social
scientists who would argue with these
rough percentages I think if I'm proving
the rape part now let's turn to culture
what defines a culture is a set of
values and ideas that underlie the norms
that we create to govern and organize
social life our culture defines morality
good and evil appropriate inappropriate
behavior so what are the cultural values
the ideas that govern relationships
between the sexes we can see it I think
as anthropologists would tell us in our
language here are those values one
relations between women and men are
adversarial there is a battle of the
sexes award between the sexes - it is an
uneven battle I'll forget patriarchy in
the phenomenology of rape culture women
are the ones in power men are one down
two women women's beauty their sexuality
inflicts an injury on men she's
ravishing stunning a knockout bombshell
dressed to kill a femme fatale sex is a
battle and when when a couple has sex he
wins and she loses she puts out she
gives it up he gets some gets over on
her hits on her he's a stud she's
[ __ ] sex is then the violent restoration
of the way things should be we top it
bang it beat it hit it nail it plywood
poke it pound it Ram it finally we win
and restore the natural balance we get
even in a letter to the New York Times
denouncing sexual harassment guidelines
a college chaplain wrote that and this
is a quote the way young women dress in
the spring constitutes a sexual assault
on every male within eyesight of them
okay so there is a rape culture and
women are perpetuating our men by how
they dress just because there's a
general rape culture that does not mean
that it's uniform across all campuses so
I'm gonna talk a little bit about some
of the variables that predict rape
Patronus or rape freedom after the
anthropologist Peggy Reeves Sande what
are the variables that predict this
what's the social ecology of rape
culture where when let's map it first
what kind of degree does the does the
school offer I know this sounds weird
but community colleges have much lower
rates why because many of the structural
features of sexual assault a social life
that revolves around campus residential
life party culture weekend sports life
are missing second who are the rapists
one in five college women experienced
some form of sexual assault but it's
only five to six percent of college men
who are committing sexual assault about
six rapes over their college career many
sexual assaults on campus are committed
by serial predators
what is the serial predator need unlike
the lone serial murder on Criminal Minds
the serial rapist needs motive a sense
of entitlement to women and an alarming
contempt for them opportunity sexualized
spaces and one more thing
support community a culture of silence
that he interprets as approval remember
this is not the old stereotypic rapist
who jumps out of the bushes he's the guy
who eyes you seductively when you walk
into a party dances with you
flirtatiously
and seems so solicitously chivalrous in
making sure your drink is always
refilled he usually needs a place to be
a space that sexualized and a place to
go as in upstairs to his room and a
sense of Brotherly support
the sense that he has approval indeed
admiration of his friends
that's a rape culture time also matters
there's the redzone the first three
months of college life from first year
orientation to Thanksgiving break when
about half of all assaults take place
this is not spread out over evenly over
a woman's four years recent research
found much higher rates of sexual
assault among first year women than
among second year now it might simply be
that higher rates among Greek Greeks and
athletes are because they tend to have
the houses where you have parties on all
college campuses that have that have
registered Greek letter fraternities and
sororities sororities are prohibited by
charter and by law from serving alcohol
at parties the fraternities are
permitted to do so subject to local
alcohol rules which everybody flaunt
that means that the guys have the
parties that the parties happen on guys
turf they control the space they control
the drinks and finally there's the
gender culture the way that those are
some sins about the battle of the sexes
inform how young people interact with
each other every year since the
mid-1980s UCLA psychologist Neil Malamud
has surveyed male students quote
attraction to sexual aggression unquote
their interest in and willingness to
engage in acts of sexual aggression in
his research between sixteen and twenty
percent of the male respondents said
they would quote commit rape unquote if
they could be certain of getting away
with it
when malam has changed the word commit
rape to quote force a woman to have sex
unquote
between 36 and 44 percent of the men
said they would as long as they would be
certain they wouldn't get caught most
recent data twenty seventeen thirty two
percent so rape culture is not about the
prevalence of rape it's the remarkable
prevalence of not reporting of not
believing women or believing you won't
be believed
pretty much everyone acknowledges that
sexual assaults on campus are
dramatically underreported so we can
only get a glimpse of how pervasive it
is it is possible that women as well as
men are likely to miss perceive what
would legally qualify as rape or
attempted rape as a date gone bad in
fact according to
according to one survey it less than
half of the women who had experienced
something that fits the legal definition
of rape actually described what happened
to them is rape now you'd have to engage
in some pretty strange epistemology to
conclude that if they don't define it a
trait as rape it wasn't rape crimes do
not depend on victim confirmation but in
a rape code but but that's a rape
culture a culture in which what is
legally defined as rape is explained as
normal as dating etiquette now remember
this most important fact most men do not
make this choice most men do not commit
sexual assault seventy-five percent of
college women are not assaulted even if
all the men in the survey by Malamutes
who said they would force a girl to have
sex even if she didn't want to because
they knew they could get away with it
actually did it it would still be quote
only unquote half of them can there be a
rape culture in which the overwhelming
majority of men do not rape of course
rape is excused or exonerated and
unnoticed and still men don't rape a
third of men said they would force a
woman just have sex if they knew it and
still one-third of women don't commit
rape so here's here's what how I will
conclude the truth is we shouldn't even
be having this debate that we're having
a debate like this at all is evidence
that I think we live in a rape culture
imagine if 20 percent of all Jewish
students on college campuses had
swastikas painted on their on their
drunken bodies during drunken parties or
if 20% of african-american students had
nooses draped around their necks at an
equally drunken party why is the
astonishingly high rates of assault of
women in LGBT people tolerated not
because it's wrong of course it is
because we live in a rape culture there
is a rape culture on American college
campuses data don't lie the good news is
that despite these cultural assumptions
these values and the overwhelming
likelihood of exoneration most men are
better than the culture they live in
thank you back
what was about was about one minute all
over Rudolph what a minute yeah so uh
you took eleven minutes that's fine well
you need to get it in that's okay
Kathy you have eleven minutes Rudolph
give Cathy eleven minutes to speak for
the negative
take it away Cathy so when we talk about
the idea of a rape culture on campus
we're not talking simply about surveys
studies and theoretical analysis we're
talking about real cases that involve
real people and here is one of them that
unfolded this month at Yale University a
student named safe Ullah Khan went on
trial on charges of sexually assaulting
a female classmate this was a rare
campus case in which the criminal
justice system actually got involved the
the young woman said that Khan returned
with her to their dorm after a Halloween
party and a concert when she was so
intoxicated that she was half conscious
barely walking and repeatedly vomiting
while she said she had only a vague
recollection of what happened later she
felt certain that he had forced himself
on her when she was in no state to say
yes I know caught on the alien said that
they had consensual sex which was
initiated by the young woman that she
was an active participant throughout and
became upset about it the next day karna
was acquitted and this outcome was met
with great anger from anti-rape
activists and feminists commentators
especially because of defense tactics
that were decried as quote as survivors
worst nightmare
above all the Falcons lawyer quizzed the
young woman about her sexy Halloween
costume to suggest that she was
interested in sex with Korn many cited
this is proof that campus sexual assault
needs to be handled by college tribunals
rather than courts since victims will
not find justice in the male-oriented
legal system a columnist for the Yale
Daily News or Edith Cowan who was
suspended from university more than
three years ago when the charges against
him were filed
should not be allowed to return since
allowing him to return to campus would
validate victim blaming this is the kind
of case that is very often invoked as
evidence of a rape culture and yet
look at this case by people who either
attended the trial were interviewed
jurors including my recent colleague
Robbie suave showed an extremely
different picture karna turns out was
not acquitted because the young woman
was slut-shamed about her sexy costume
but because the evidence contradicted
her story specifically her claim of
extreme intoxication was not supported
either by witnesses were crucially by
security camera footage of her on Khan
walking to the door well she said that
it shorter being led by Khan with her
eyes closed and one foot dragging the
jurors actually saw her walking with him
her arm around his waist his arm around
his children evarin on her face the
jurors also heard that the young woman
actually spoke to somebody on the phone
while Khan was in her room and seemed
entirely conscious they heard that when
she first went to the campus health
center to ask for emergency
contraception she initially said she had
had a consensual encounter and later
after speaking to her friends she
apparently came to the conclusion that
she had been raped
one female alternate who was interviewed
after the verdict insisted not not only
did the prosecution not prove guilt but
that the facts showed Khan was innocent
many advocates for survivors tell us
we're complicit in a culture of rape if
we give Khan the benefit of the doubt I
would say that if we do not give Khan
the benefit of the doubt we are
complicit in a culture of injustice one
may ask of this case was an outlier and
yet a remarkable percentage of the cases
we hear about as evidence of a campus
rape culture involve intoxication
usually in both sides and foggy memories
also often on both sides now of course
intoxication is not an excuse for rape
being drunk doesn't excuse raping
somebody the fact that a woman is drunk
doesn't excuse raping her but typically
in these cases the claim of rape or
sexual assault rest solely on
intoxication the person usually the
woman occasionally the man being too
drunk to consent certainly this has been
true in a lot possibly most of the cases
we have seen in which male students
expelled from college after being found
responsible for sexual misconduct have
sued for wrongful expulsion here's
another case this one at Ojai
University in Athens Ohio in October
2013 two students who had just left a
bar late at night engaged in a drunken
public sex act specifically the man
performing oral sex on the woman that
drew a small crowd of spectators and of
course was caught on camera
the next day photos in the video went
viral on the Internet and the female
student suddenly aware of all of the
stuff going around went to the police
saying that she had no memory of any of
this and that she had been sexually
assaulted the male student was charged
and this was a rare case usually in
those cases of course everything happens
behind closed doors here we actually had
not only eyewitness testimony but actual
video of the sexual activity and both of
those confirmed that the woman was fully
conscious or certainly appeared to be
quite willing and even enthusiastic at
one point apparently encouraging the man
to continue when he saw the crowd of
onlookers and said well maybe we should
stop she also walked away with him
unassisted and in view of all these
facts the grand jury brought no
indictment what happened next was that
the campus activists rallied against the
this decision and to the woman's side
this incident was invoked as evidence of
a campus rape culture of glamorization
of sexual violence I'm using some of the
quotes that came from the activists
survivor blaming and refusal to take
rape accusations seriously Tara called
Bressler a blogger for Think Progress
defended the sexual assault charge
against the man noting that witnesses
said both of the participants were
severely intoxicated now of course the
operative word here is both if there is
a glaring double standard here imagine a
jungle reversed situation in which a
woman was giving oral sex to a man in
public and they were both very drunk
it's entirely possible that the Stu
would have been perceived as sexual
assault but certainly not in a minute
there have been many studies which
Michael referenced over the past thirty
years dealing with the subject of campus
sexual assault and its prevalence and in
fact I have been contrary to what
Michael says many polemics about the
methodology of these studies and what
they mean yes they all sort of come to
this
result because they all use somewhat
similar methodology now doesn't matter
that most of the women who are
classified as victims and many of these
surveys don't think they were raped even
in today's environment where there is
extensive education about sexual assault
I would say that it does do these
surveys measure rape or sexual assault
or awkward sexual encounters and
miscommunication
does it matter for instance that there
is a very reputable survey which shows a
very different result that's the
National Crime Victimization survey
conducted by the Justice Department
which asks people about sexual violence
in the context of criminal victimization
as opposed to in the context of sexual
activity and that survey finds that
about 4 out of 1,000 college women every
year or raped or sexually assaulted
which certainly doesn't add up to
anything close to 1 in 4 or 1 and 5 over
the course of one's college career it
should be noted by the way that the
National Crime Victimization survey
specifically asks people about being
assaulted by someone you know so it's
not about people thinking that
acquaintance rape is not real rape I
should also add by the way that sexual
assault is often defined very broadly
it's defined sometimes broadly enough to
include unwanted kissing so III think
some question is definitely in order
when we talk about some of these studies
I will also say one thing I think that
it will soon be impossible and is
probably becoming impossible already to
conduct a reliable study of rape or
sexual assault on campus because the
definitions of sexual assault and forced
sex are being hopelessly muddied by
sexual assault education on campuses
young people for instance are routinely
told that all sex while intoxicated is
sexual assault which is not the law you
have to be incapacitated not simply
intoxicated they're taught that any
unwanted sex is sexual assault even if
you never signal your unwillingness and
of course by these definitions a lot of
men have been sexually assaulted by
women a one large survey at the
University of New Hampshire in 2005 in
which students of both sexes were asked
about these expiry
winces found out about 40% of those
reporting sucks when too drunk to
consent for male know if rape culture is
as Michael was saying part of this
gender system in which men are seen as
dominant over women it really doesn't
make sense that we have so many you know
putative male victims by the way we also
have some college officials explicitly
advocating a double standard several
years ago
a Duke University Dean explicitly said
when testifying in a case of a male
students suing the school that when both
parties are drunk when it's a male and a
female quote it is the responsibility of
the male to gain consent before
proceeding with sucks you know at one
point the feminist critique of how
society treated rape and sexual assault
had a lot of valid points feminists
correctly pointed out that women who
were sexually assaulted were often
expected to put up a serious physical
resistance to prove non consent this was
not expected of victims by the crimes
this was discriminatory today we seem to
have gotten to the point where we say
that when a man and a woman are in the
same situation will hold only the man
responsible that is not a quality I
think we can certainly argue that
drunken sex where you barely remember
the the details the next day is not
healthy behavior we can educate young
people about it I think without creating
a dichotomy of victim and perpetrator
and certainly without assuming
victimhood by gender
of course sexual violence happens
according to the National Crime
Victimization survey it happens on
campus less often than it does among non
college people in the same age group but
certainly colleges have a legitimate
interest in preventing sexual violence I
think we can do that without conflating
rape with irresponsible sex without
creating double standards and in many
cases demonizing men while patronizing
women and I think we can do it without
creating a paradigm of rape culture that
is hostile to the open discussion and
debate about sexual assault I think we
should be able to have conversations
like these without being told that they
contribute to rape culture and I think
we can do it also without creating a
definition of rape culture
to the presumption of innocence Michael
uh five minutes of rebuttal you can
check the podium okay I'm sorry that I
operate from a distinct disadvantage I'm
a social scientist so I don't argue from
anecdote I argue from evidence sorry as
a result I have to say these surveys do
not use similar method
they do not use similar methods in fact
the one survey that Kathy used the
National Crime Victimization survey is
the one that is least used to talk about
campus sexual assault for many reasons
one one of these is it's because it's a
National Crime Victimization survey and
people know that that's it so they are
already much more likely it may inhibit
their reporting second the National
Crime Victimization survey does not
ensure privacy third it does not ask
about incapacitated rape it asks about
rape attempted rape or other forms of
sexual attack all of the other surveys
the public health surveys the criminal
justice methodologies undertaken by all
of the other surveys including those by
Bonnie Fisher at the National College
women's sexual victimization survey use
very different methods and they all come
up with about the same percentages but
maybe we shouldn't be arguing about
percentages because maybe percent maybe
I just haven't reached the threshold
only only 25% maybe we can dismiss that
so let's talk about something else let's
talk about why about why women don't
report I don't think there's very much
there's very much disagreement maybe
there is about very very few women
report sexual assault according to one
survey 12.8% sorry 5% of of women report
sexual assault now why would that be so
low why would that be shame self blame
fear of reprisal fear of being
ostracized reading articles by Cathy
young but remember that 9 out of 10
offenders are known to the victim
usually a classmate a friend or an
acquaintance 12% of completed rapes 35%
of attempted rapes and 22.9% of
threatened rapes take place on a date
somewhere about half of those both
perpetrator and victim had been drinking
so is their hyperbole of course there is
exaggerated distorted claims of course
there was not Kathy offered several
anecdotes about cases we but what we
don't have is a full analysis of all of
the cases that have been of those five
percent that have been fully adjudicated
that would be an interesting study any
graduate students the audience want to
do a dissertation because that we do not
have we do know that that over 90% over
90% of those who have been assaulted
don't report they because they believe
that they will not be believed I think
that is significant and I think it also
is significant when we get to the stage
of adjudication which is not the area
that we're talking about now I'm simply
arguing about the presence of rape
culture adjudication is a completely
different matter but it does matter to
me that if I see somebody reporting to
me and knowing that only 5% report I
suspect she has a pretty good case at
the outset I suspect she does precisely
for that reason so I have one suggestion
for this and I think this is something
that Kathy and I would agree about
here's a here's an idea in universities
I've been I've spent my 40 years in in
colleges and university of large public
universities in California in New York
and New Jersey and I have to tell you
over those 40 years when we get students
who are coming to college today who are
unprepared for college at work we have
all kinds of remedial of remedial
programs for them we have required
remedial writing programs we have
required remedial math programs all of
these because we recognize that they are
ill-prepared for college life so why
don't we have mandatory comprehensive
sex education in our colleges because
ours too
are coming to us with either no comp no
sex education abstinence based education
sex education which is even worse than
no sex education they think that online
pornography is their sex education and
you are I'm sure I don't have to tell
you how that the average age of first
seeing online pornography is about seven
and by fourteen ninety six percent of
boys have seen online pornography they
think that that's their sex education so
here's an it show here's an answer I
think we probably would agree on Mandic
comprehensive sex education as a
remedial tool to reduce the likelihood
of sexual assault on campus because the
students are coming ill-prepared for
college a college life which I argue is
includes a rape culture thank you but
500 barrel Catholic reject the pony
could you from there which I want to
check the poem okay take it away Kathy
so first of all I wanted to fund the MCV
yes the National Crime Victimization
survey when Michael said that the format
of asking about criminal victimization
inhibits reporting because a lot of
people don't think of acquaintance rape
as a crime actually the MCPS was
redesigned in I believe nineteen
ninety-four precisely in response to
those concerns so that now that they
specifically say well now we're going to
ask you about sexual violence and by the
way we want to remind you that sometimes
sexual violence and sexual attacks
happen between acquaintances and
sometimes we don't think of it as a
crime but you know if you have been
attacked etcetera etcetera so I I did
they actually have specifically tinkered
with the survey to make it more
responsive to these concerns and they
still get that pretty low right now
regarding the Bonnie Fisher study I
think this is what I was driving out by
saying that a lot of these studies in my
view have the same faulty methodology I
think the really the the sort of the
elephant in the room is that the
questions about so-called incapacitated
rape really make no distinction between
you know rape when
you're passed out or barely conscious
and you're sexually assaulted in which
case I don't think any person of any
decency would doubt that this is in fact
sexual assault and that the person
should be you not only expelled from
college but hopefully prosecuted and
convicted and these are certainly
predatory actions but they're the
surveys make really no distinction
between that and incidents such as the
ones I described in which you're
intoxicated you do something that you
wouldn't have probably wouldn't have
done when you're a sober yeah a lot of
us have done those things you know
sexually or not and then you know when
you realize the next day what you have
done in in some cases you see video that
on the internet you know suddenly the
year you're like you know what did I do
and you know this really was not what I
wanted to do and I think this is where I
think the culture I mean I mean you know
Michael is talking about rape culture I
think there is at this moment a sort of
culture for young women in many cases of
encouraging them to see rape in
incidents that you know maybe should be
seen as poor decision-making in many of
these cases the women when they've had
these drunken experiences they go on to
speak to their friends they go on to
speak to a counselor and they end up
being told that they were raped I mean I
have a friend who had this experience by
the way on on a college campus 20 years
ago this is not Avenue where she was
told she went to speak to a counselor
about this experience that she felt was
very ill-advised and she wanted to you
know talk about how to improve her
decision-making skills and you know deal
with these situations better and instead
she was told oh no you really shouldn't
even think about that because you were
right now my friend happens to be the
kind of person who it doesn't
necessarily you know follow every bit of
advice that she gets who has a pretty
strong sense of you know
and agency and who felt that that was
extremely demeaning her to basically
tell her that she's not responsible for
something that she did in that situation
but I think that many young people who
have little experience I think that is
very tempting so you know I think this
is the the real issue that we have to
deal with when we discuss whether it's
surveys and you know the reason that I
wanted to discuss anecdotes is behind
those surveys you know we don't really
know what these answers mean and I think
this is the kind of thing that we really
need to look at to understand what these
what these numbers on the surveys refer
to in terms of comprehensive sex
education a lot of schools right now
have mandatory workshops on consent
mandatory workshops on basically healthy
sexual communication I don't have a
problem with you know having a system in
place in colleges to help people make
healthier decisions sexually to help
better communication and relationships
and so on I do have a problem when these
educational programs set up a framework
that kind of reflexively blames men or
that were when these programs promote
the sort of legalistic requirement of
well you know everything that you do
sexually has to be negotiated and
verbally and signed in triplicate so you
know that's I think it really depends on
what kind of education we're talking
about Thank You Kathy
we're at we're going to the question a
part of the evening you may want to
start lining up at the mic over there to
ask questions the two debaters have been
told that if at any time they want to
toss a question at the other side they
can exercise that option
Michael Kathy at this stage do you want
a question at the other side what do you
want to bide your time okay but Kathy
why not you okay you're both good but
remember our guys to make sure that
you're holding the mic not far from your
mouths the only of course give the usual
give you I'm getting the usual
instruction to the questioners please
ask your question pose it as a question
and wait for the answer to the question
so first question please take it away
all right this question is for Michael
um during your intro you said that if
I'm not mistaken you said something
along the lines of society does not want
to believe women somehow to me this
seems like a C it suggests that society
can countenance the fact that women are
being assaulted and that they're fine
with having rapists at large I'm
wondering like what arguments you can
proffer to defend that that's opposition
saying is how seeing is how it also
seems to be the case that on college
campuses administrations are readily and
willing to defenestrate due process
rights for the accused did you I you
want to summarize the question as you
understand it and then addressing the
the question the question is as I
understand it before the before the part
about due process going out the window
the the part is that I argued that rape
culture is a culture in which women are
not to be not believed right that's what
I argued and you are asking me
yes you said explicitly during the
beginning that the cult that society
does not want to know right those were
your exact words if I'm not mistaken
right because and and I said society
doesn't want to know because we have no
nationally representative survey of all
college students to get the kind of so
we are relying on campus numbers which
all come about the same and all of these
large-scale surveys which also come and
come back come out roughly the same so
so my my argument was why don't we want
to know why don't we want to know the
answer to this there is no it is there
no political will to know that to get
the right data and my argument is we
don't want to know because the data
would say would tell us that there's a
high prevalence of rape on college
campuses and most administration's do
not want to spoil their brand by finding
out that you know by having to tell
people who are applying to their elite
colleges oh by the way about twenty
twenty twenty five percent of the of
your other female students here will be
sexually assaulted and about ten percent
of the men Kathir you want to comment
please pick up the mic if you do really
part of this whole at this point that
was just made really goes to one of my
problems with the whole sort of rape
culture paradigm which is this statement
that you know rape culture is a culture
in which women are not believed about
specifically about rape first of all do
we have any evidence that male victims
are believed any more readily than
female ones I mean I would say that if
anything it's the reverse that there's a
lot of there's a lot of data actually
showing that male victims I think are
even less likely than women to report
sexual abuse and even less likely to be
believed I mean until very recently the
sexual abuse of an underage male by an
adult female was not even a crime and
you know it's
sort of it's changed and we have all
these situations with you know female
teachers going to jail for sexually
abusing boys who in some cases are as
young as 11 or 12 and there's still in
many areas I think there's a mentality
of well you know he just got lucky
because you know Ian's sex is a teacher
so I think that there is you know I
think there's certainly a history of
have there been unhealthy attitudes in
the area of section sexual assault sure
I would say that they don't necessarily
victimize only women in in terms of you
know who is affected which victims are
affected by these attitudes but I've
been also questioned of this premise
that you know believing people who come
forward with a specific allegation is
somehow a sort of moral obligation in
terms of having a kind of a non rape
culture so to speak I mean the
presumption of innocence is a
cornerstone of our justice system and I
think you know we can debate to what
extent do we owe somebody the
presumption of innocence in the court of
public opinion it's certainly not the
same thing as as an ax court of law
but even so I think with with certainly
in terms of the culture in general we've
moved towards a belief that you know
there should be a presumption of
innocence in the court of public opinion
which is why you know the media for the
past 40 years or so will refer to
somebody as an alleged you know
perpetrator
rather than you know a perpetrator so I
think this notion that somehow in the
area of rape there should be an
exception to this and that you know a
you know the proper cultural attitude is
one of belief for anyone coming forward
with an accusation of rape really seems
to me very dangerous and this is what I
was this is the point I was driving out
when I said that the rhetoric of rape
really is in my view hostile to the
presumption of innocence Joanna coming
Michael I think he proved that there's a
rape culture when you also say that boys
aren't being believed neither is being
believed so there's a rape culture on
college campuses that creates an unsafe
environment for both female and male
students I'll go with that
next question this one is for Professor
Kimmel you for your for your position
you said that something like 90% of
victims do not report the rape
so rape has a specific legal definition
and so does harassment as a subcategory
and part of that is both rape and
harassment have to be proven beyond the
reasonable doubt so when you say the 90%
of victims don't report it you're also
presuming that all of those were actual
crimes program beyond the reasonable
doubt now a hundred percent of those 90
percent let me finish 90 percent of
those 100 percent of those could be
adjudicated and there could be rape or
harassment you could be zero it could be
something in the middle but to just
presuppose that because 90% of them
don't speak up that there is actually
rape is well it's not logically
consistent I think that yeah I don't
disagree at all look I'm making no
assumptions about guilt or innocence I'm
saying that 90% of women who made the
legal definition according to for a
forced or unwanted sex it's a do not
report it now would that rise to the
level of proof beyond a reasonable doubt
I have no idea neither do you
neither does anyone that's fine but my
point is that most women who have
experienced something that meets this
legal definition do not report it now
that's not simply the law is a blunt
instrument and it's a disaggregating
instrument it looks at each individual
case on its own individual merits I have
no problem with that that's simply what
it is but what I'm suggesting is that
there's also a context in which women
for
long time would say you know this
happened to me and their female friends
would say you could ruin his life you
don't want to get him in trouble and
they wouldn't report it now some women
were likely to say that and other women
are saying I will go with you we are
going to take this to the title 9
coordinator this is wrong so there has
been a significant change on college
campuses and the and the rates of
reporting have actually gone up several
percent over the past five or six years
now you may say that this is a problem I
say I look at it as good news women are
recognizing what happened to them they
believe that they're entitled to be
believed and that they believe that
they're entitled to have it adjudicated
well first of all I and I did want to
comment on those before when we talk
about ninety percent of women who
michael said who had experiences that
meet the legal definition of rape I
don't know that we know that because
again a lot of those numbers are based
on surveys that include so-called
incapacitated rape which basically means
rape when you are too drunk to consent
and a lot of those surveys as I said are
phrased in such a way that we really
have no idea whether the respondent was
actually incapacitated were had their
judgment clouded by alcohol to the point
where they did something that they
wouldn't have done when sober so I think
we really have no idea what what the
real rate of non reporting in those
studies is if we're talking about you
know actual sexual assault that meets
the legal definition if you look at the
numbers if you look at the reasons that
women and a lot of those are women only
surveys so we're talking about I'm
mentioning women that they give for not
reporting it's not primarily because
they say that they won't be believed I
believe the number one reason is that
they don't believe this was such a big
deal I mean that is the number one
reason it didn't think it was that
serious
I and you know where I I felt that it
was a private matter so you know the
real issue obviously for some people it
is that they're afraid of
being believed they may be afraid of
retaliation they may be afraid of you
know ruining their own reputation or
running the guy's life for many people
it's that they really do not regard this
as a criminal act in terms of yes there
are more women coming forward and having
support from other women in some cases
that's a positive thing in some cases it
may be one of those situations I
mentioned where you have an experience
where you did something when you were
drunk you're not feeling so great about
it you talk to your friends about it
and the advice that you get is oh this
is actually not your fault you were
raped and you know you you don't you
don't have to take responsibility for
this instead you go to the title 9
office and report it as a rape I mean
this is I'm not just using this as a
hypothetical this has happened in
specific known cases in which you know
that the complainants did not even think
of reporting what happened and didn't
think of it as a sexual assault until
they spoke either to their friends or to
a counselor or just somebody from the
final nine office I don't think this is
always a good thing sometimes these
cases are very obvious when you look at
the facts very obvious sort of
travesties of justice these are they
kangaroo court cases that we've heard
about so you know I think that in some
cases certainly there has been a
positive change in awareness I don't
think it's it's a kind of unqualified
positive development so next question
for the people in a panel if right now
we're talking to my rape on college
campus if we change the narrative for
one second and interject prison how
would that change either one of you
point of view on that yes if we we taken
out college campuses and we're adding
the prisons to the scenario we're still
rape actually something that I've
written about I actually do think that
this is a vast
the underreported SEO and you know this
is an extremely violent environmental
where very often people are actually
coerced even if there's no sort of overt
physical force there is coercion by
threat of force there's a tradition of
not taking it very seriously I mean you
know we've all decided a while back that
rape jokes sort of demeaning women's
experience of rape are unacceptable but
they're still quite recently there than
many instances of people making jokes
about you know someone who is about to
go to prison about you know don't Dunn
Dover to pick up the soap but cetera et
cetera
you know that's kind of regarded as
acceptable cultural currency really so
so I think this is one area where I
think we I think it really does need to
be taken more seriously and that
definitely changes does it
sure there are many arenas in which
there's a significant rape culture rape
is used as a way that some groups
dominate other groups this is true in in
war
wait rape has become a weapon of war it
is true in prisons it is an evidence of
inequality and that inequality is
exactly what I am talking about on
college campuses men run the parties
they serve the alcohol they filled the
drinks they decide who gets into the
party and who doesn't get into the party
you it is an irony that I have been
working on for many years that probably
the most gender equal place I can think
of in the United States is the American
college classroom by day and at night
it's a completely different arena and
here's how you anthropologist again
sorry would tell you that you can read
power relationships by how people dress
who dresses up for whom by day walk into
any college classroom everybody's going
to be dressed the same t-shirts
sweatshirts jeans
sweatpants flip-flops running shoes
everybody's dressed the same at
night the guys are still dressed exactly
the same the women are wearing cropped
tops heels short skirts and makeup you
can read power bi who dresses up for
whom by day it's a gender equal world at
night it is not at all equal
structurally and interpersonally rape
happens in instruct instructors in
institutions characterized by inequality
period full stop military prison sports
team initiations and also of course the
American College campus access
moderators prerogative to ask you a
question Michael two-fold question do
you think that the rape culture was very
prevalent in the 60s and 70s is it a new
phenomenon on college campus and then
second do you find will you teach at
Stony Brook that there is indeed the
kind of rape culture that you speak up
25 percent of women have been raped will
you teach well I've been part of the
online college social life survey we've
we've surveyed 25,000 students so any
Brook was one of the sites of that was
initiated by Paula England when she was
when she was at Stanford and Elizabeth
Armstrong at University of Michigan and
myself we have 25,000 students so the
answer to that question is by percentage
yes the answer to the but yes yes about
about 20% of Stony Brook women have
reported sexual have have met the
criterion whether they label it or not
so that's that answers the the second
part of your question the first part was
is this a new phenomena is this new true
when you and I were going to college um
we're all it was I don't I you know to
be perfectly honest this is the thing
that I I tried to wrestle with when I
when I wrote guile and some years ago
was the fact that it didn't seem all
that new much of the behavior and then
and yet it feels more pervasive now more
intense and for and far more more
consistent I do think that this is a
this is something that has been going on
for a very very long time and that it
took a long time for women to say you
know what this isn't okay just as women
started to
starting in the 1980s and then
culminating of course in that great
historical moment in 1991 when Anita
Hill testified about what happened to
her was women are starting to speak
about this and for once finally they're
being believed the me to moment I will
say this it I categorically is can is a
sea change because for the first time
women are being believed and I think
this is really revolutionary so you
think the rave coats was probably I
think it when you were in college the
level of casual racism homophobia and
sexism when I was in college was
astonishing and what and and frankly it
was sort of like segregated water
fountains in the south it was normal we
just thought it was normal that sort of
way what the way things were and it took
a whole bunch of women in from you know
so in the 1960s and 70s and say this is
not normal this is inequality and we
won't put up with it you know and even
and to confession might you know I was
the student leader activist in my on my
campus and my girlfriend types my
speeches that seemed normal to us that
is but now it seems that it's a women
have come forward to speak about these
things and say this is not normal she
touches pieces but you didn't rape her
but I said yeah sure I understand okay
um do you have a comment you have a
comment right yeah I actually do have a
comment okay first of all I mean I would
really sort of question the idea that
you know the fact that our cultural
norms right now is that women dress up
you know in a way that men don't does
that necessarily you know is that
necessarily a measure of inequality
favoring men I mean I don't know I mean
there were times in history when men had
extremely elaborate fashions in and no
less so than women they weren't exactly
times of more equality necessarily I
think many women would many college
women who
some that way would seriously question
the notion that you know they're
necessarily dressing up to please men or
that you know this is some measure of
being subservient I mean you know I
certainly wouldn't mind saying you know
it's seeing more kind of male dressing
up but you know that's you know my
personal view but I really question
whether this it's a little too
simplistic to describe that as an
equality and the other thing that the
other point that I want to make this
Michael sort of comes back to this
gender analysis where sexual assault is
a function of again of male dominance if
it is a function of male dominance what
do we do again with the fact that when
we survey both sexes on these issues and
now Michael said 25% of women 10% of men
I've seen surveys where it's a lot
closer than that were probably you know
about 40% of those reporting sexual
assault in the past year or males so you
know is it it is the rape culture and
issue of male dominance which is the
typical analysis or if it's an almost
gender neutral issue what sense do we
really make of that and is it really
rape culture or is it possibly a sexual
culture that you know that has norms
that some of us may not approve I mean
there's a lot of reckless sex there's a
lot of drunk sex there's you know sex
that possibly involve sort of aggressive
physical initiation of sex that doesn't
again necessarily translate into actual
force or actual violation I think that
again we're conflating a lot of
categories here and I think this is
really one of the stumbling blocks to me
you know if if this is if the rape
culture is an expression of male
dominance you know what do we do with
the fact that there are so many male
victims apparently if we if we use these
definitions which you know I
personally don't but if we use those
definitions we end up with a lot of male
victims ah Thank You Cathy next question
please
hi so I guess I have one question for
each of you so for the professor I was
just curious you said many times that we
should believe the victims and I'm sure
most sane people will agree that it is
extraordinarily difficult to actually
prove rape
for instance beyond a distinction with
rough sex so how would you wouldn't you
feel that it's slightly hypocritical to
essentially place the burden of proof on
the defendant ie believe the victim
instead of burden of proof on the
plaintiff which is the core of criminal
justice in this country
and for a Cathy well you can ask
question of Cathy let Michael respond
and then you can okay hold your question
yeah Michael look very few prosecutors
are gonna take a rape case when it's
he-said he-said she-said because they're
unwinnable people prosecutors get
promoted on the percentage of win of
wins so they're not gonna take these
cases so III there's it's another
disincentive to reporting if you're say
if you're saying to me that we should
put the burden of proof on the plaintiff
to prove it that's the burden of proof
is put on the state to prove it not the
end not the victim the state has to
prove a case which is why it's so
difficult to prove these cases and why
so many so few women come forward III
think it's a pretty easy pretty easy
answer you want to comment Kathy or you
want yeah I think I sort of commented on
this before I mean I agree that the
burden of proof is technically on the
state in in criminal justice cases there
is a complicated issue of how do we
decide these cases in the court of
public opinion you know do we label
somebody a rapist a sex offender on the
basis of an accusation I mean I think
this is a very very difficult issue to
wrestle with and we can't resolve it
simply by saying believe the victims I
mean there's been a lot of debate about
what is the rate of false accusations
and
I've written about this issue other
people have written about this issue one
number that gets cited a lot is the only
two percent of rape accusations of false
other have said it's eight percent the
problem is when we talk about studies of
false accusations we only know about
cases that are definitively proven to be
false that doesn't necessarily mean that
all the others are true I mean in the
same studies a lot of cases remain
unresolved so we actually have no idea
what the rate of false accusations is
and it doesn't even necessarily have to
be full citations in the sense of
someone deliberately lying I mean then
in a lot of these studies they will say
that you know there's a certain
percentage of cases where the accuser
believes that you know she has been
raped
especially cases involving again
intoxication but the facts really do not
support the accusation of rape so I
think that this notion that full say or
where wrongful accusations because
they're not necessarily false in the
sense of again being a deliberate lie
but to say that wrongful accusations are
so rare that we can just dispense with
that risk of you know wrongly accusing
someone and we can decide to believe
because we know that supposedly that the
overwhelming majority of accusations are
true I think that's a very very
dangerous mind side and I mean I could
give you examples of what I think are
really troubling examples of a sort of
accusation equals guilt mentality when
it comes to rape accusations I mean
including that there was there was a
story in the news a couple of years ago
involving James Dean who's an adult film
star who was accused and there there
were very complicated accusations from
several women some of which were later
retracted but the thing that I found
really interesting was there was one
woman who was a friend of his who
basically said yeah well I sort of I
personally know that one of those the
initial accusation is for
she said I happen to know them both and
I happen to know that this is a false
accusation and she said this by the way
in a private message that later became
public and she said but I'm not going to
say that publicly because I really
believe that we should support victims
and I really don't want to add to a
climate in which victims are not
believed and this was someone who said
that she personally had knowledge of you
know the accusation being false I think
that is actually kind of terrifying you
know as somebody who believes in the
presumption of innocence I think that
this is not only bad for men because
this is again often framed in terms of
you know that the the danger to men from
false accusations I think undermining
the presumption of innocence is going to
backfire on everyone including women and
the example that I always cite in this
context is that all the examples you
gave an example there's a question for
so if you'll forgive my pointedness I
come from a mathematics background so
statements
I mean you've made a lot of claims and
argued your points ideologically but I
was wondering if you could actually
offer aggregate statistics to
substantiate the claims that you're
making
that's the Kathy what I mean I gave you
I don't know that I made that many
claims that were centered on statistics
I mean no I mean but respectfully those
are the only claims that possess any
merit if you don't have any statistics
to actually substantiate your arguments
they I don't think that they would hold
any water
well okay can you give me like an
example of one statistic that you would
like to well I mean you you've presented
like a good array of ideological
arguments but I'm saying that if like
you've presented several anecdotal
instances as to where it's all right
well you know I can tell you for
instance that a law as I said that the
studies on on campus rape often rely on
a
survey question that doesn't distinguish
between incapacitated rape and basically
drunken sex that is later regretted I
don't have any statistics because nobody
has actually broken down those those
studies so you know that the statistics
actually don't exist that I agree that
we should have better studies I mean I
think that when for instance somebody in
one of those surveys says that they had
that they had sex when they were too
drunk to consent maybe there should be a
follow-up question what does that mean
you know were you sexually assaulted
when you were unconscious did you have
you know sex when you were drunk that
you later don't remember I mean this is
the problem I think we don't have any
statistics in a lot of those areas I
mean the one statistic that I did give
you which you know which I think is
important is that when people are
specifically asked in the National Crime
Victimization survey whether they have
been a victim of a sexual assault in the
past year the rate for college women is
something like four out of a thousand so
you know I'm not and again you know I'm
not saying that that necessarily is a
measure of the real rate of sexual
assault but I think we don't have any
good statistics and many of those areas
so I'm not really sure how I I think
there are some really good statistics I
read them earlier I'll read them again
the MIT survey which was the college
sexual assault survey and the online
college social life the one that I
helped design they asked about forcible
rape they did not ask about they did not
include the unwanted touch and grabbing
etc the forcible rape was 8.5% when you
add attempted rape and incapacitated
it goes up to between fourteen and
twenty six percent depending on the
survey so there's three different three
different large-scale surveys of many
different campuses then the ones that I
gave you of the individual campuses of
which there are many and I urge you if
you are really interested if you are
really interested in methodology look at
the shift study that has been
at Columbia because it is going to be
the state of the art and many many
campuses are going to be following this
and and it was and it was done precisely
because of all of the problems that
emerged after the mattress girl Emily
silk awaits and the and the accusations
of of the the guy who she accused of
assault so there are great statistics
out there but they are incomplete and we
have no nationally representative the
mattress girl was the woman who walked
around with a mattress around Columbia
yeah just clarify yeah give you Mike
please yeah next question please
hi I have two questions
nobody really talked about the incidence
of rape outside of college versus the
incidence of rape within college is
there quite a difference and second of
all if there is really a fourteen to
twenty six percent chance that my
daughter will be raped in college in two
years should I keep her out of school
because that seems like a very dangerous
proposition Kathy I want to dress that
in there Michael
right well the as I said the National
Crime Victimization survey shows that
there is in fact a in the same age group
there is a lower risk of sexual assault
on campus than for people of the same
age off campus and certainly we know of
very high crime environments in which
you know typically very few people go to
college you know the poverty-stricken
neighborhoods that have that have a very
high crime rate they I would say almost
definitely have a higher rate of sexual
assault and rape than college campuses
but again I mean these measures the
measures that actually look at the
crimes that people report in surveys
that deal with criminal activity they do
not show anything close to an 18 to 25
percent of of women being sexually
assaulted so
you know I I think that sending a
daughter to college is pretty safe
frankly look of you know I until 1975
every single state in America had a
marital exemption from for rape
it wasn't until 1993 that every single
state had made marital rape illegal you
still got married right it's you you
know one one is it was aware of risk and
one should be but my feeling is if we
take all of the different variables that
I laid out we can identify the places
that are at highest risk for a sexual
assault there are certain parties during
a certain time of year with certain
groups of guys with a cook with a sense
of community support for that so my
feeling is we can address that that's
the culture part that's not the
adjudication of individual cases that's
the changing the culture part to reduce
that risk my son is a freshman in
college and I want him to have a
terrific experience complete with really
great sex well but you but you but but
uh but so I want him to be aware of all
of this but a question for you Becca you
you are saying though to this woman who
asked the question she's sending her
naive daughter right now to college and
you were saying that naive daughter
she's just add 18 she has one chance in
for of getting raped well is that right
but oh that what you're saying I am
saying overall that's that's what the
data show oh well no wait yeah however
her right if she's a friend her freshman
year highest rate one chance of - what
no no no no no I'm just saying the
highest rate Oh between or freshman
orientation and Thanksgiving over half
the rapes take place maybe have a go
second semester what what I'm saying is
you have to be aware of all of the
variables that produce that are part of
this culture it is not a simple cross
the board 25% that's what I'm saying
being aware of that so there and and
every campus does you know women tell
other women how
to reduce their individual risk for
sexual assault you go to parties with
friends you never lose eye contact you
taste each other's drinks you you oh
wait you follow each other to the
bathroom if you have to you make sure
that your friends are safe but right now
there's a one chance of for risk okay I
mean I just
well actually I believe that even though
the figures that Michael was sighting
before it don't actually show one in
four risk of being raped it's a kind of
more broadly defined sexual assault
including attempted rape and you know
and again you know the the definitions
when I said before by the way I kind of
want to come back to what I said before
which is that I think it is becoming
very difficult to to do a reliable
survey of rape on college campus because
of the way that young people are being
taught about a sexual assault and
consent and I mean I'm not even sure how
people define physical force anymore I
mean does a kind of physically
aggressive but not necessarily coercive
you know move count as physical force I
mean it's I think it's becoming a very
very treacherous water next question
thank you it's good next question hi I
have a few short questions I'm hoping we
could figure out together that might
frame this debate
can I ask you professor Kimmel about how
many women's centers would you say are
on campuses in these cut in this country
women's centers and centers yeah across
the country I don't know these probably
women's centers at most college campuses
it's not you know I would say what 80
percenters I'm probably one to two
thousand given that there's 1,000
campuses how many men's centers are
there what's that how many men's centers
are there how many men centers are there
well I run the Center for the Study of
men and masculinity at Stony Brook I
believe that was the first men's center
in this country man Center it's a center
for research right and but it's there
are there are centers for there are some
centers for men but not many okay when I
read about it a handful when I read
about the opening
the article said it was the first one
for men and when I read your website
actually said there's a Center to study
toxic masculinity how it affects how it
affects inequality for women now even
the one men Center apparently studies
how men negatively affect women not the
problems faced by men so not true okay
okay first of all toxic masculinity is
not a phrase I would use okay I don't
and and secondly that it's not that our
our mission is to understand
masculinities plural to understand the
different ways in which different groups
of men understand masculinity to talk
about the jet to talk about gender
relationships men men women's
relationships men's relationship with
other men so I I don't I don't think
that that's our mission in the slightest
here's the question given that there are
one to two thousand women's centers
across the study basically none for men
it seems like women's centers is a
billion-dollar industry at least we know
that since at least 1979 women have
outnumbered men in campuses across
re-education still there's not one men's
center and we also know that for the
last few years at least women are 70
percent more of college students than
than men according to Department of
Education the federal Department of
occation statistics so do you think that
perhaps rape culture this notion of rape
cultures is a notion that your industry
is dependent on to get billions of
dollars in funding from the federal
government and and do you think the
second part let me just finish and I'll
be done please and do you think that
that if a grad student decided hey I
would like to get funding to write a
thesis about how many men are are
victims or that there's no such thing as
campus rape culture do you think a like
flora Kipnis you get a he would get a
title 9 complaint against him for like
you said earlier yourself that very fact
that we're having this conversation is a
is asserting rape culture and be do you
think there's any money out there to
fund that statistic and therefore we're
only getting one side of the story okay
that that's gonna have to be the last
question because we're now John Oh
Michael oh please from your mouth to the
funders ears we have there's no funding
at all for this there's no political
will for this if only we this was a
billion dollar industry will be so happy
but look this is this is a this a
serious question you talk about the
percentage of women and the percentage
of men that women constitute 60% of all
college students everybody knows this
women women would get most of the honors
there seventy-five percent of all high
school valedictorians are women that
there's a big boy crisis let me just
tell you there are more people going to
college than ever before
it's not that men's men are going like
this and women are going like this
that's how you think about it the
reality is both women and men's rates of
college of college attendance are
increasing the rate of change among
women is greater than the rate of change
among men but it is in no way that men
are disappearing more people are going
to college every single year period so
that is a false a false framing secondly
I just want I want to say our Center is
part of a Gender Studies conversation
that is part of you know just as if I
were to establish a center for whiteness
studies to understand what how white
people might think about different ways
of being white
obviously whiteness is like
masculinities and of course we're going
to be in conversation with all of those
people who've been talking about race
for all of these years thank you Michael
we've run out of time and do you or
you'd ever burning me for comment good
Kathy nobody okay Michael you you are
going to do your summation and that's
five minutes followed by Kathy and then
we're going to take it to the final vote
so listen closely to the summations and
think about how to vote take it away
Michael
okay I think I'll just sit here if
that's all right you can you can you can
stand out I'll sit here god yes okay I
my summation is going to be fairly
simple first I think that
we are we are in a moment that is as I
said before the me to a moment is I
think revolutionary and I think it's
revolutionary and it's it's a it's a new
way of thinking it is what I think of as
a Confederate monuments moment one
minute the Confederate monuments
throughout the South were just those
quaint southerners who didn't realize
that they lost the war and they were
memorializing therefore the lost cause
of the Old South the lost tradition etc
and then two years ago suddenly we
realized oh my god those people love
slavery they were defending slavery
that's not right
that was a moment when we when we took
off a certain lens put on other ones and
said that's not normal we are living in
the written in a culture right now that
is undergoing what used to be normal in
the workplace is no longer normal I grew
up thinking my workplace was going to
look like Don Draper's my father's
workplace did look like Don Draper's you
know which meant all the men had the
offices with the windows and all the
secretaries were gathered in the center
and sexual access to those women was a
perk that is no longer acceptable we are
living in a time of tremendous change
and I would say this to the people in
this room that we are that this is
changing as we speak in real time so
many of us many of the the surveys about
about sexual assault in the me to era
I'm sorry about sexual harassment in the
me to era are talking a lot about how
age is a factor in understanding this
because like baby boomers and older we
grew up thinking that this was going to
be our workplace it's not normal what we
thought was normal is no longer I say I
think that this is equally true on
college campuses what we thought was
normal in answer to you is no longer
normal sec secondly i have i want to say
i have a great idea if you really want
to think it think this through with me
i'm arguing that rape culture is not
necessarily ideological it is structural
it is in the way we organize our
institutions when sororities are
prohibited from serving alcohol at
parties and only fraternities can do so
they're the ones that have a party i
have a challenge for any college and
university in this country for two years
i want only the sororities to serve
alcohol at parties and they
we'll be the ones at the door and they
will be the ones to decide if you're a
gentleman enough to get in I know some
guys will slide slide their way through
but basically if she gets so drunk that
she's incapacitated she goes upstairs to
her room and she closes the door my
feeling is I don't know I'm a social
scientist I have a hypothesis
my hypothesis is sexual assault rates
might go down worth a try don't you
think finally I want to say III wouldn't
I can't I can't imagine that we would
have an argument that there is not an
adversarial sexual culture between women
and men because we talk about it all the
time so I think that we have to deal
with with that I think that men have a
major role to play in this and I think
that the role is positive because I
think that what we're looking for is
actually better relationships and yes in
fact better sex ending rape culture
means that both partners end up showing
up more more consciously and more and
more pent and more present so I have men
have a major role to play and so I have
an idea about how we might go about this
I'm going to show you something now the
men do you know what this is anybody
know what is it bingo yes the piece that
goes in the urinal exactly it's most
people call it the urinal think don't
worry this is a new one um this is
called it has a technical plumbing
supply name it is called a splash guard
and it goes in urinals and when a group
of men on a particular college campus
decided they wanted to do something
about rape culture they put these in all
of the urinals on campus and if you use
it as directed you would see you hold
the power to stop rape in your hand and
I would say to you tonight you hold the
power to stop rape culture in your head
I feel like you want to take the Claudia
I'll say okay yeah I'll stay five
minutes for cafe for information so yeah
I just want to quickly say first of all
the me to moment I think a lot of people
including many women have certain
misgivings about it I think they believe
that it's great that we were taking down
powerful sexual predators who take
advantage of their position to sexually
abuse their not particularly happy about
a conversation that places on men all of
the blame for sexual miscommunications
and sexual misunderstandings were
redefining sexual relations in such a
way that again you know all the problems
are always seen as a result of male
malfeasance
as far as Michael's last comment goes
with the splash guard
I remember that bit from his book
Garland and I was actually wondering
when I read that how would people feel
if for instance somebody decided to put
signs on mirrors in a Muslim Center on
campus saying you are looking at
somebody who can stop terrorism I think
this is you know when we have this kind
of collective blame when we're basically
telling every man that he is a potential
rapist and especially when we're looking
at situations many of which really do
revolve around misunderstandings and
miscommunications I think this is
extremely counterproductive I think this
is really not the way to go this I mean
people who the real rapists are not
going to be the real predators are not
going to be stopped by a sign that says
you know don't be a rapist because I
think that's actually a very very bad
message about rape it really sends this
message that rape is the result of you
know a misunderstanding remembe is
communication I don't think you know
that certainly bad sexual experiences
happen to those I think when we label
that as rape I
we're actually sort of unwittingly
exonerating the rapists and yes of
course real rapists and real sexual
threat or is do exist and again they're
not going to be deterred by saying you
know be a nice person they're going to
be deterred hopefully by fear of
consequences as far as the sororities
serving alcohol i believe it's this
aurora isn't it the sororities
association that makes that choice so
it's it's up to them i mean it's not the
beta market forcing forcing this
different standard on them it's the
sororities own decision so i'm perfectly
fine with the sororities you know
choosing to serve alcohol at their
parties I mean I'm all for that I'm you
know you know not that I've ever been
part of the sorority scene but you know
but I have no objection so I think again
you know we need to differentiate the
conversation about rape which is a crime
which is you know a very serious crime
from the conversation about ethical
sexual norms and responsible sexual
behavior I think those are different
things and you know we absolutely need
to have a conversation about ethical
sexual norms and good sexual behavior
and I think one problem that is
contributing to this situation that we
have right now is that a lot of the time
we seem to we've gotten to a point where
we seem to be unable to talk about
irresponsible reckless
you know hurtful sexual behavior without
making it an issue of consent I mean yes
consensual sex actually can be
irresponsible reckless bad hurtful etc
etc so these are again these are two
different conversations and lastly yeah
I think that there's a real danger when
we say that to merely discuss something
to discuss the possibility of false
accusations to discuss the existence of
rape culture is itself a part of rape
culture because that
to me in dangers not only you know the
presumption of innocence not only
relations between the sexes it also in
dangers free and open debate and that I
think is a real problem okay well first
of all thank you to you both
both very energetic articulate and
raising our awareness of these issues
thank you Michael and thank you Cathy we
are now taking it to a final vote the
people on live streaming of voting the
people in the audience are voting and
again this is just a game this debate
was just a sort of intellectual sprint
you may want to read Cathy's articles
Michaels articles we post in Michael's
book about these issues but certainly
both debaters taught us a lot this
evening I want to take a moment to
announce next month's debate that will
be on Monday April 16 and in that case
the debate will be about the following
proposition fractional reserve banking
poses a threat to the stability of
market economies quite a change of pace
from this evening that will be professor
Robert Murphy opposing George Celgene
Robin Murphy will defend the resolution
fractional reserve banking poses a
threat to the stability of market
economies on Monday May 14th Bryan
Caplan George Mason University economist
and author will defend the resolution
all government support of higher
education should be abolished against
Edward Glaeser professor of economics at
Harvard University Kate how are we doing
on the voting first of all both sides
won so to speak those who voted yes for
the resolution were initially 17% and
that rose 117 percent of so I'm sorry
17 percent I should have said because
let's not confuse it with 70 percent
yeah 17 percent and that rose to
25.6% so you picked up eight point five
points Michael congratulations those who
voted no word 47% and that rose to 61%
so you picked up thirteen and a half
points Cathy the Tootsie Roll goes to
Cathy young but certainly both debaters
trade some of the winnings